they would be though screaming at you at
half time they'd be screaming you at the
end of the game
told of that
David the Messiah boy is one of the best
known football managers across the globe
building teams with a clear identity
I was desperate to be successful as a
manager and I had 11 years where you'll
find it really difficult to break into
the top four the phone line who said
Alex and he said I'm retiring and you're
the next manager of Manchester United a
new interview not saying would you like
to be I met Edward on the next day back
to his house again we met the Glazer it
was three days and that was as simple as
that to get that offer from the greatest
manager maybe it ever was was a great
compliment but maybe if I'd really
looked into more detail and more depth
there was a huge change going to have to
take place I trusted Manchester United
do you feel like that trust was let down
definitely but my biggest regret was
we start with the story that has
dominated the front pages the sacking of
David Moyes how did you find out that
you're losing your job media oh really
if you've got any class or any style you
have to give bad news wheel
what are those steps forward to get West
Ham competing at the very top of the
table I want to build a new West Ham a
lot of supporters might not like the
sort of that when you look at where West
Ham is now do you worry about losing
your job I've got to see it
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
take me back to the context that I need
to understand in order to understand you
take me back to Glasgow
1960s yes
I was in a really good family
who were really important and you're
probably going to be talking a lot about
it now but uh we were a
family who we stayed in the West End of
Glasgow in a tournament building
and uh we used to have to you know go up
this up the tournament and if people who
don't know what a tournament is a
tournament is a you know what we would
probably think I bought block of flats
and you got the tournament
and they were never in Glasgow that at
that time very very uh good to look at
people look down on them a little bit
but it was a great upbringing for me
that allowed me to play my football out
in the street which at that time was was
some which everybody considered you know
Street footballers everybody played
football on the street and everybody in
Glasgow did play football in the street
played in the park
so I started in Glasgow in the West End
and that was probably where me and my
family grew up your father's also called
David he certainly is yeah
what did he do for a living
and how did that influence well well
this is probably is a really good
question to me if for me is because but
that actually was a teacher but he
worked in the shipyards in in Glasgow
which was really important so he walked
in the as a shipbuilder and then he went
on to become a teacher in a college
but meanwhile what he'd done in in his
part of his other job was that he was a
an amateur Football Manager and there
was a very famous boys club team in
Glasgow called from Chapel amateurs
which was very famous and really is uh
all my memories come with my Dad running
one of the teams at Drum Shop armatures
now for the people who don't know you
know there's people like uh Sir Alex
Ferguson played with him Chapel amateurs
there was people like uh ASA Hartford
played for Trump and she was John Watt
was a Scottish International so it was a
very very famous boys club
uh my dad also ran uh the college where
he teached my dad was a teacher at
Annie's Land College which was a college
in Glasgow
and he uh he took the team every
Saturday morning and then he took the
amateur football team every Saturday
afternoon you've got to remember this
result well there was no no money
involved in this
so really part of my life was seen my
dad grow up as
a football manager for amateurs uh
but meanwhile his real job was that he
was a teacher at Town Eastland College
did that make you want to pursue that as
a career at that time or what what kind
of influence has that had on you in
hindsight
well I think when I look back now I'd
say to say to I think your parents are
viewed a huge influence and everything
you do
for different reasons
mine definitely did but I don't think
when you're growing up as a boy you're
thinking that you know I'm going to be
influenced too much by my dad or my mom
you don't think that's you get a bit
older yourself and when you look back
you go wow I can't believe that I'm
quite similar to my dad or I can't
believe it I followed my mum
and going back to that you know my mom
was part of it as well my mum had to
wash the strips and hang them up outside
and you know and then she'd have to wash
them and I she'd wash them and iron them
and I'd be folding them and put them
away so probably from a really young boy
I was watching my dad and my mum
uh help help young young boys at that
time no fulfill go for a game of
football hopefully they were all home to
going to become professional footballers
but if not try and be successful playing
for for the boys team in Glasgow at that
time one of the things we do tend to
pick up from our parents from what I've
seen and I certainly did myself was
I guess like principles and values of
like how to approach life and how to
deal with life
um what were those principles and values
that your parents imparted on you
directly or indirectly from observation
about life and how to deal with it and
how to confront it
well I think your parents will always
influence you in some way
um I was sent to church when I was when
I was younger so I went to church a lot
of people were
and I think that probably had an
influence as well in its own way in the
in the early days but I think more to do
with schooling uh more to do with uh
education and and what they they try to
do and to be fair
none of them I was never pushed on
innocent I was never pushed to know to
be that well educated I was never pushed
out to be a great football player they
were just encouraging really and always
daily support so I had parents who
really let me grow up the way the way I
chose to do so but everything was Guided
by them you know respect uh no trust you
know
trying to be truthful all the time all
those things I think come into a good
relationship did you ever have a you
kind of suggested there that they
weren't necessarily like pushy parents
necessarily but did you ever have any
idea of what career or aspiration would
make them proud
if I'd asked you you know what does your
mum or dad want you to be when you're
older when you're younger what would you
said uh I think my dad would have
definitely said I hope you're a
footballer you know I think that I think
my dad would have always probably
thought that he's a great love of
football as well
but I think they were they were always
really supportive in in anything I
wanted to do but I think you know as I
get as I got on and I got to an age
where I was starting to get coarse I
know 12 or 13 I think football was
probably my my biggest sort of love and
what I wanted to do and I was more
interested in either watching football
playing football
and there and that was probably they
probably saw that around about that age
as well and is it sort of 12 12 years
old you were in Celtics Youth System
yeah it was what it was is it that time
Celtic Celtic had a boys club and you
have to remember my dad also as I said
ran a very very famous boys team or one
of the teams in in Glasgow and drum
Chapel Armature so but I went to Celtic
boys club uh
and applied with Celtic boys club from
Mob is about 12 to 16 till went on but
they were they were brilliant years I
had there
you know the my time at cell taken which
uh you know came after as a player in a
and as a you know a senior professional
not a senior professional but a
professional I should say but the Young
The Young period when I was at Celtic
boys club was I can only remember being
winning things and being really
successful and you know representing no
Glasgow schools as a school board as
representing Scotland school schools as
a Schoolboy International so I had
really really uh good days in the early
days probably from 1459 onwards did you
if I'd asked you even at that age so say
when you were 16 if I'd asked you
about your Ambitions in football
what would you have responded with uh
I I hope that I might have been good
enough to to become a player I'm not
sure I would be uh
and I would love to be involved in
football and I always used to think that
you know
I'm hoping that maybe I could run an
amateur team or I could be involved I
could maybe might be good enough to take
a junior team you know might get paid a
little bit of money
you know maybe maybe I'd become a youth
team coach for someday if if you know if
I wasn't going to be a football player
always thought even at that time when we
were growing up was like lots of use
clubs no so we would go to a school
youth club you know because it was where
you'd be getting my table tennis you'd
play pool you know the gym might be then
you play five aside football no whoever
was there it's always thought well maybe
I might be able to use club or something
if I didn't get her if I didn't get any
more better than that so those early
days there was no guarantee that you
were going to become a footballer if
everybody really wanted to become a
footballer what did you learn from your
dad as a manager is there anything even
today where you think I think I've got
that from my dad or that trait or that
yeah
planning yeah organization
commitment
and if I just talk about planning you
know at that time
there was no mobile phones then so it
was it was a phone so he'd be phoning
all the playoffs they say look we're
playing on Saturday I want you to meet
at 12 30 we're meeting wherever it was
and at that time they all had to come at
times with the same with a shot and tie
on they had to bring her back you know
they all had to come with the same bag
shot in time you've got to remember this
is Glasgow in a time when you know
people well people had to turn up we're
calling tie on if you didn't turn up
with your car and tie on you might not
get selected for a game so small things
like this
if you're talking about maybe
disciplines or or ways you were brought
up I think possibly I picked up a lot of
the traits probably early on why does
that matter where do the small things
matter shirt and tie
uh do you think they matter I guess is
another yeah I do I think they really do
matter
I think sometimes I mean and I have to
say in if you if you jumped onto this my
senior time I think
I think they've always looked better I
think players people have always looked
better if they dress well and they
they're correct they look prepared for
the games
I jumped to Manchester United just
currently in Signal Manchester United
had a rule which Sir Alex had that they
would always turn up for away games and
shutting ties now most teams would
rather turn up the tracksuit players can
come more casual but Manchester United
always turned up uh with a shot and tie
on which I thought was a great thing
because they wanted to show what they
were wanted to come out there and say
look the way we look the way we approach
it you look at this Manchester United
and I I've got to say I really admired
admired that part of it
it's interesting it's an interesting
small psychological advantage isn't it
to some degree if
I guess it's a statement of
professionalism and
attention to detail before the before
the ball's even kicked
yes and uh you know so that takes me
back so you're saying is no maybe Sir
Alex who played with from Chapel
amateurs maybe maybe it picked up from
his timing from Chapel Armature so you
know the way they they they had to turn
up shut the ties on and they had a
Blazer on
and again let's reaches the number to
football team in Glasgow you you um you
played with many many clubs over your
almost 600 career
um games
a few across a variety of different
divisions
um
that time working as a player across
multiple clubs and multiple divisions
what did that teach you and it's always
useful to get a variety of different
experiences so that you can kind of
create your own perspective on on the
world but what did that teach you those
600 games as a player
what are the fundamentals the
fundamentals where I learned so much but
my but my early days when it when I
started at Celtic was probably engraved
in me more than anything because Celtic
is an incredible tradition of winning
you know winning now obviously Celtic
had to win with style as well celt it
were you know the biggest cobweight
Rangers in Glasgow in in Scotland I
should say and and because of that
Celtic had to to win was always so
important so oh no I could see that
there was the first team there was the
reserves there was the the youth team
and all the managers were under pressure
to win then if you did win then it was
and what was the score you won one
nothing that's not good enough you need
to win you need to win three or four
nothing you need to win buy more codes
and how did you play well we didn't play
that well we scored the known it was a
Scorpio not good enough you have to win
with style so I think my early days I
would I was brought up with brilliant
footballers
people who
showed me
I don't know if you want to call it a
philosophy because philosophy might be
much deeper and might offer much more
but it gave me some way how do you say
well I have to win I have to find a way
of winning you know if I can win with
style that's even better but more
importantly I have to find a way of
winning and I picked that up probably my
early days at Celtic and I wasn't near
that long
no that wasn't here that long but I
wasn't here that long probably as a
senior player I moved on and ended up
bobbing around the championship in a
couple of lower leagues in England for a
long time
but I come across some some really great
managers
uh I can't come across so much we aren't
so good
but you know I always try to be
respectful to any of them because that
came from from my background in my my
upbringing
but I also was trying to pick up
everything I could in
when I was
20
I had already qualified as a as a
full-time fill a license coach at the
time you know to be a coach you had to
have an a license it was called
uh now you have to have a pro license
but you have to was it was an e-license
I'd qualified as a coach when I was 20
21.
which was unusual the reason I'd done
that was because
the coaching courses were
obviously full of really experienced
managers feel a really lots of players
trying to get into management the only
reason I went and done it was home that
would become a better player I thought
that if I went on these coaching courses
it'll help me become even better as a
player and I had a I had a really good
career but not quite at the only level
which uh I really wanted to be whose
idea was that to go and do a coaching
course at 20 years old to improve
yourself as a player uh my own because I
thought that maybe I'd find out more
about it but I have to say
there was a thing when we were we were
young players we were when we were 16
bit Celtic we were sent
to the courses to help the coaches so we
were called the runners so we were down
here to do all the running you know you
had to do all the running you had to be
a feel bad you had to remember Midfield
player and you and all the practices
were put on for the coaches
and uh
no Scotland had great great coaches at
the time you know people people at Sir
Alex Jim McLean you know Walter Smith
you know what I could go on and on
Scotland did brilliant coaches without
naming the likes of jockstein and
no bill shankly and and what you could
go on and on George Green for example
so I I was sent down by Celtic and I was
one of the runners for a couple years
and once I was down I said oh I want
more of this I want to be around
football people I loved listening to
them
I hoped I would impress some of them who
were who were managers of really big
clubs at the time
and that's what I thought well no I'm
gonna go and do my badges myself and
went on to went on to do them in
Scotland well your time at Celtic um in
the first team when you got signed there
was three years right you were in Celtic
yeah yeah
you then got to experience other
cultures and clubs but you you cite
Celtic as having that sort of winning
mentality that some clubs just have
where they're almost you know yeah
they're just they get used they like
develop the habit of winning
throughout your career you've been in
clubs that have the habit of winning
um but also clubs that maybe have
struggled in the opposite direction and
don't have that culture of we always win
every game when you think about the
clubs you've worked in that have that
habit of winning like Celtic did what is
that how is where does that come from
and what what does it look like and feel
like
it it looks like you walk in every
morning with your chest
out in your head high
and you saw confident in what you're
doing there's a a motivation to keep it
going not to let it drop
there's a
something about having to continue to
improve to stay at the top that you
can't just do what you're doing which is
going to keep you there forever you have
to keep trying to find a way of doing so
I I did see that and I feel that and
I've seen it at other clubs since
but I have to say I think on the journey
to probably
where I am today is probably more that
seeing a lot of the other side as well
is actually the bit which you know I've
been a cop so I've been getting
relegated I've been at cops but I can't
win I've been at clubs where you know
it's not going well but it comes with us
you know it's it's not been as powerful
as as say a couple at Celtic
so I think I think you have to see a
all round for you to give yourself the
best the best chance and I keep saying
as you know
to do to get to become a football
manager
I don't think there's any one plan you
could be the best player on the planet
and not become a football manager
you could be someone who's never played
the game and become incredibly
successful as a football manager so
I don't think that's necessarily one way
you do it I'm really intrigued by this
this idea of like cultures at clubs and
within teams and how you can just feel
it almost when when a club has that
momentum and they were winning team and
when they don't
um on the on the country then when we're
thinking about teams that are struggling
that aren't performing well
um
what are the signs of that now Rio said
something really interesting was it real
wasn't Gary Gary Neville said something
interesting to me he said that when he
was a
um Manchester United Sir Alex Ferguson
only came into the dressing training
ground dressing room twice
and he said he never needed to come in
there because the culture was in there
yeah so if like when Berbatov came over
and wasn't fitting the culture the
players would correct him he then says
when he went to QPR
when the manager left the changing room
everyone was talking about their wages
and where they're going next you could
you can feel that like yeah there is a
difference I actually think the culture
I mean
that that team you're talking about
Manchester United where we had
incredible players and you know I
wouldn't say self-made because they had
they had a great manager but if you want
now if I moved to just now I'd be seen
as
just much more communication in life now
I came from background it was really
tough the Scottish managers you know
they
probably the working background we came
from uh they they would be out screaming
at you at half time they'd be screaming
you at the end of the game you know they
would be
there would be they'd be after you if
you didn't do well I don't think that
culture's there and I don't think I
think it's changed completely in
Scottish managers and if you look a bit
Scottish money just probably over
history Scotland had lots of managers in
English Premier League for example
very few now and it might be that we're
having to change your culture so going
back to a little bit where you're
talking about Rio said get in there I
think there was a period where the
players looked after themselves or they
could take the hard hitting hair dryer
treatment if you want to call it that
no I think it's a completely different
culture now whether we've changed or
whether I feel as if management is not
necessarily in that form I don't think I
don't know maybe you Steve you tell me
even better your head of businesses
would you go in and be screaming or
Bloom Lobster at your staff now do you
know what the thing one of my actually I
think is an advantage is I didn't grow
up in that culture yes so I've never
known it I've never known the prospect
of like coming into work and like as you
hear about it in some old businesses
where like the CEO would come in and
throw things and throw the table over
and stuff yeah I just never grew up in
that environment I grew up in a sort of
a societal expectation that a manager is
like
you know might be tough and sometimes
but it's fairly nice yeah there's no
like big glass office that I sit in away
from my team members it's a different
world these days well as you relate you
were talking about there you said that
it's kind of a different world in
management you've been in you know the
job since you were I guess 20 in your
early 20s you're 59 now I'm 59 and I've
probably been in management since I was
early 30s or when I started and then so
25 30 years
um you talk about the change that you've
seen in the approach that is effective
now
what is effective now if if Once Upon a
Time Scottish managers could come in and
hair dryer it and scream whatever
whatever how is the approach changed in
your view well let me tell you I
remember I remember one of the managers
coming in
to the dressing room
and I always said is don't look up just
look at the floor look at your boots
look down because if you catch his eyes
he's going to come for you so so it used
to be don't woke up so that it couldn't
have any eye contact with you and you
had to you know and you'd probably put
your head in a towel so that he couldn't
see in an air because that was the way
it was we were it was that and I think
that I probably had a lot of that in me
when I first started
but the difference now is as I think
we're in a different and maybe maybe
yourself or maybe you'll understand it's
a different era so as a coach and as a
manager and as a manner I think you need
to find a way how you're moving on with
that or you'd be left behind and I've
got to say I think in my position I've
got to admit I have to keep trying to uh
keep up renew invest in more work and
find out how it's going on there's so
many new things and it that don't get me
wrong that doesn't mean that I've still
not got the bit of
I can get in me when I think the players
need it and I actually think that
I like not like it
I think sometimes like I think I think
people want to be told the truth
and I think one of the the worst things
you can do to people is is I think if
you keep praising people all the time
I think it makes you soft as well so I
think there's a level of Praise You can
give people but I think you've also got
to be really tough with your Trace as
well and I actually think that as I've
got older I've become better and giving
praise I think there's some of my
players I'm sure Everton would say that
I very rarely gave them praise because I
I was always looking for better from
them
you know over the last when I've been in
business what 10 years or something
um not not as long as you in terms of
management but um even I've started to
notice some like warning signs in people
so like if I see this in the interview
process I go uh well I've been I saw
this before and then it ended in this
way like pattern recognition yeah you've
talked a lot about I've read a lot about
your scouting process how you find great
talent great players
what are the things you look for in the
things that you consider to be warning
signs
I always wanted someone who I thought
was putting in effort okay I always
thought that and they might say well how
can that come in front of many other
things well
I can think of many probably you and
you'll think of plenty of school boys
friends who were truly talented player
but baby didn't weren't dedicated and
put in the effort to didn't do the work
I think if you don't put the effort in
the dedication to it then and the other
thing what I use a lot of is you know if
you don't love the game completely
then you'll probably find it really do I
think you'll find it really difficult to
become a manager if you don't love the
game with or have real longevity I think
you could be a player and maybe get
through your your career 10 15 years as
a player with maybe without loving
football but I think if you want to go
longer I think you've badly got it love
love the business
when I became manager of everything but
I did it before I used to always meet
the players and I still do if I can
you nearly wanted to see their eyes to
see
I need you to work hard I need you to
know to do this job for the team I'd
like to see a you're going to take that
I'm going to be critical of you and I
want you to get better are you happy
with it you nearly wanted to put the
questions over to them to see if they
were going to take it did you I did too
many for us and I've I've got to say
we've had quite a few of the time which
I've got to say who I've had in my house
who have had in uh
offices and we've probably not taken
them sometimes because a bit like you
said sometimes something just makes you
go that's just not what I quite wanted
to hear
and that might only be a gut and it
might not it might have no reason to buy
some of the boys I'm talking about I've
gone on to be Superstars and play for
another time but something at the moment
can only give you that little bit of gut
feeling if you think it it sounds like
it's going to fit for you
I'm not saying you get it right but I
think at that time you have to have your
own
things were you say no I'm not going to
change this is what I want to do and I
want to keep it this way and I some of
I've missed out on some
how does that process work if you're
looking let's say you're looking for a
striker what's the process you know
because we've heard some I I don't mean
we're only understanding of like signing
players is playing like football manager
on the on the PlayStation or whatever
but I have in my head you have all these
Scouts they produce reports yeah and
then do you know what position you want
to fill do you go to the Scout or what
happens uh I think you in the main the
scouts will probably bring them to you I
mean look if it's somebody playing for
one of the teams locally or that and is
available and you think there's a chance
then you'll probably try and do your
homework you're trying you know
obviously statistically you'll try and
get it right you'll try and look at the
strengths and weaknesses you'll you'll
take any consideration maybe the price
is going to cost where you think it's
you know where it fits in for you what
you can do but the ones you don't know
are what you you're looking for your
Scouts to bring to you and and quite a
lot in modern footballs the agents are
bringing them you know because the
agents are putting such a huge part no
whether you see it as a positive or A
negative they're playing such a huge
part behind the scenes in football at
the moment
and these people will bring it obviously
if you're trying to sell something
you're always going to talk it up but in
the end you know we would or I would
always try and get my Scouts to go
through it they would probably say yes
this is what's coming and looking at
come in we should we'll go and set more
we'll sit for a few hours watching
if we wanted to take it even further
then we would go into much further
detail would eventually probably start
trying to find out
people who know the boy or just played
with a boy and try and get a bit of his
character background
would try and find out more about
you know is he that is he the right type
you know is he is he a good boy is he is
he a good trainer is he going to be
disruptive in the training I think all
those things are really really part of
it I don't think any I don't think any
football manager
wants people who are not going to fit in
in what was it and I guess again uh
reverse back to business probably you're
the same and you don't want people here
not going to fit in with what you've got
you want somebody who's going to come in
and blend in and be part of it what was
your best ever signing
ah but I always say
Nigel Martin is saying Nigel Martin the
goalkeeper who was at Leeds United and
he was on a free from Leeds United and
we took him to Everton at the time
and it's only because he was a three but
not only that he was a great goalkeeper
obviously he had been an England
goalkeeper he was probably near at the
end of the time but he gave me about
four or five years of stability
but see when people talk about signing
your best signing over the over the time
I've now been I've made that many
signings I've got you know it would be
it's really pretty shame for me even in
M1 because I've got so many that I could
I could see you don't have to I would
not ask you to name your worst signing
but where have you frequently got it
wrong when signing players
you know what I think you do is I think
it's the ones I've missed the ones who
you've said no I don't think is quite
good enough I think I'm gonna don't
think I wanna and I've had hundreds of
them who's the one you missed the most
that well just recently because it's
because because we've been talking about
it you know we've been
Alvarez who's just played for Argentina
in the World Cup you know was I I
brought in a new Scout who says look you
should go for Alvarez at River play
and I watched and I watched these are
very good really good technician I
thought he he done so many good things
as a center for a bit I thought maybe
not quite the one we want maybe didn't
quite we had Mickey Antonio uh who had
been doing very well I don't know if
he's you know
and you see sometimes the players change
in six months but I have to say there's
other other players like that who you
don't take and don't go on to be a real
success but that one at the moment is
just one because it was probably only a
year ago where I decided nah I don't
think it's probably the one we're gonna
take it's the same in business no matter
how many people you hire yeah it's
always still guessing yeah and I was
speaking to my friend Gary vaynerchuk
about this who's hired about 5 000
people and he said to me he says you
know I've been in this game for 30 years
and I'm still just guessing because
we can come up with all the principles
and systems we want but how someone
people change but also how they present
in an interview yeah can be drastically
different to how they present in six
months time yeah when they're
comfortable you know what which really
interesting I'm asking you I I hear now
and I hear because there's so many jobs
change in our our industry
he says how do you pick a good football
coach now how would you pick a football
manager whatever you want but how would
you pick a good football manager no what
would give him the no the owners or the
people who are doing it how are they
picking it because again what I said it
says
yes of course we can think of some real
special people who would be would be in
that group but if you're you're a lesser
Club trying to pick a new Talent when
you know why would you get it is he got
the driver has he got the energy has he
got the love for the game to to to stay
with it has he got an idea that he wants
to go further and he's going to put the
work in
it's really hard and sometimes you can't
find them and I get the feeling it's the
same in Industry now as well yeah
um yeah I I think the more I've hired
The more I've realized that it's just
guessing which I think would people be
surprised at because people think that
you'll get progressively better or your
your confidence will will grow my
confidence has actually Fallen with
experience yes so so what that means for
me is that when I hire someone and I
know it's not right just very quickly
have to make a decision because the
worst thing is indecision right waking
wasting too long that's it we have the
same situation we've talked about as we
are buying players and we're and we're
spending a lot of money like you are and
then you're saying is and you're saying
no but you can't do this but we don't
think you can do that and and at times
maybe the older you get you would think
this it becomes easier it actually
becomes harder the more you're in it
because you've probably seen the good
ones the bad ones yeah this is before
this past they try and get a good one
but not so good anymore we're going to
follow another parcel I've got to say no
hiring people and bringing them in is
not an easy thing to do it's slightly
different I guess in business because as
the CEO
I in business usually get to make the
decision about who you're hiring I mean
sometimes of course managers at low
levels make make that decision but in
football there's often a conversation
that the board or the owner has stepped
in and has told you who to sign and who
to buy
well I think that's one of the things
really in football where you would say
laughs
if if an owner was going to do that you
say no come on it's not not right it is
it's part and parcel of football now
it's Rife and football where a lot of
owners are making the signings instead
of the manager has the owner ever asked
you to sign a player uh yes yeah they
have yeah what did you say to them I've
tried to say I've said no to you know
and I've said no it's not the way I do
what no if the players are good I'd be
I'd be saying great bring me them in but
then what we would do is if we get a
name of a player then we would try and
do our homework and try and do other
stuff and by the way we might be wrong
we're accepting that but if we follow
the correct process or what we believe
is the correct process
and it still comes out no we have to go
with what we're saying now if the
process stays here by the way where he
and he's a good player he's going lots
of goals he's you know he's young you
know resellable if it doesn't work if
all those other points come up then
we're saying oh wait a minute maybe we
have to think about it but I think
really trusting your process and hoping
that
the longevity I've had will probably
hope that you've made more right
decisions than wrong decisions by the
time
by the time you get around to making the
final decision I guess one of the things
you can control which doesn't have to be
a guessing exercise is the culture that
they join so the culture that they join
is good then there's a higher chance of
them being successful as a player as a
new signing I agree how do how do you do
that at the clubs you're managing now
West Ham have you done that in the past
to make sure the culture is right and
what is that culture yeah
well I think I think for me the biggest
one was
when I when I was at West Ham the first
time we came and we thought we'd done a
good job and we kept the team up we were
asked to come in we kept the team up and
we didn't get the job and then another
manager came in and we were we were out
of work for a year so then to be fair to
the owner David Sullivan he followed me
about companies says would you come in
and says yeah love to come back no
problem
I felt I had to do
a bit more at West Ham or had to try and
I I keep using and I say it opening a I
want to build a new West Ham so what is
a new West Ham mean well a lot of people
a lot of supporters might not like the
sort of that but West Ham I've moved to
a new stadium
it's not been it's not been appreciated
by everybody
but that's what we're going to be it
looks like for the next hundred years
that's when it looks like the club's
going to be there so we need to make the
best we possibly can of it
you know I want to change the cut I want
you I want that to be a lot it's a young
kid's Company West Ham East End of
London's a huge area former West Ham
supporters
a lot of poverty in the area West Ham
offer great ticket prices great
opportunities they do brilliant work in
the community West Ham in in EastEnders
one thing they really do
and I want to encourage all the young
kids now what do you need you need
exciting players so that these young
kids want want to buy a jersey so that
they're not following the top two or
three teams in the country and you want
them to come so
I I've tried to change
try to change the team
but you know deep down I'd really like
to say I'm trying to make West Ham
better
and it used to always do other people
when I was a manager I haven't managed
man united in other clubs before would
say oh you get a flaky West Ham you know
they're not not that reliable and you
don't know what West Ham team is going
to turn up
well I want to change that culture
there's so much room for improvement at
West Ham you know I think it's got great
potential to improve
and I I hope that you get I get the
opportunity to keep it going with a
couple of really really good years uh
success for West Ham there's been
success and it's how we continue that
success now how we build on it and I
think if you're if you're in business
I think you'll accept it you know you
quite often you have a couple of years
or a good year and then you might not
have it quite so good because we'll have
weird a little bit like that at the
moment so I'm hoping that
culturally I think we have changed
I've changed a load of things at West
Ham
we're not we're not milky we're not
flaky
uh
I think there's a different atmosphere
in eastenda London regarding how people
see West Ham
I
I like the way we've done it but we've
also got some exciting really exciting
young players who those young supporters
I talked about could fall
what are those next steps then if you
reflect back on what you did at Everton
you took them from being that kind of
you know happy to survive Club to a new
last I think your last eight years you
finished in the top you lost seven years
you finished one of the two yeah you
last eight years you finished in the top
eight seven times yes or something along
along those lines
um they became a consistent
competitive team at the top top end of
the table
when you look at where West Ham is now
as we sit here in our 16th in the table
what is what are those but after two
amazing years in the two previous years
where West Ham were absolutely fireworks
to be fair dangerous very very dangerous
team to to play against I'm not
Manchester United fan so I remember like
the last two years have been really
really um incredible for West Ham what
are those steps forward now to get West
Ham to being that team that that is
competing at the very top of the table
and I find it so interesting that in
fact when you when you answer this
question you don't just think oh we need
to buy more players it's kind of more of
a holistic wider broader job that needs
to be done yeah I I actually think that
we we bought our players and I think
that you know I've gone out there and
said that's what I'm doing
but I think I sometimes I think in in
football not that you need to break it
but we had a really good team for the
last two years
but with a few Mark Noble was coming to
them one or two other players were
coming today and we had to change and we
were actually shortly numbers were
really sure the players have done and I
felt as if I nearly had to break up a
little bit because I had seen Signs Now
my experience my longevity was telling
me if I don't do this now then I'm gonna
feel I'm going to be caught out now we
probably didn't do quite as well from
January on last year that was my feeling
we had some brilliant nights we got this
semi-final European football no we had
been challenging all years I mean we in
the last game of the season we we
finished seventh but we were 10 minutes
away from finishing six above Manchester
United you know uh
so the the margins were incredibly small
and all this but I felt that
now we might now with the age I'm the
only saying is
I don't really give a [ __ ] now I've got
to say I'm not going to get many more
goes at this so if I don't make a go to
I don't really do what I think is right
and what I want to do then I'll regret
it so this part of me said yeah we had
to bring in new players and we've gone
out and we've
put my head on the Block and said here
we go brought these new players in
no what I really need is hope that I can
get a little bit time to set on getting
them settled in I think we brought in
good players I think we have got a
better Squad
maybe not a better team at this exact
time than what we had last year but
we've definitely got better players
which are I believe will show that and
in the coming months do you worry about
that
um losing losing your job is that
something that like
sits and you might I I wouldn't in my
business I mean other than when I was at
Social and I had a board of directors
we're a public company so technically
they could fire me
um it's not something that I think about
like if I'm if I perform badly as an
executive the company goes down
well what it says I think as a young
manager I worried much more yeah I think
now in the in the position I'm in now
and when I'm going I'll worry far far
less because
it's in my blood I love the game I want
to be here I'm enjoying what I'm doing
but it wouldn't be the end of the ass if
something went wrong for me now where
I'm at but my pride my determination is
that I want to be successful and I want
a I want to know be do a really good job
for West Ham
so but I think when you're younger if
you look now at Young managers young
managers find it very difficult if you
don't do well in your first job maybe
like business you know in business maybe
you ever go and something fails nothing
quite what you're nearly tentative do
you think I could go again maybe nobody
will help invest this may whatever it
may be so it's so important you do get
it right when you do go and book them
back to if I just have to because I want
to visit
I think you need people who are really
supportive at the start I had a great
owner at Preston North End a couple of
great owners who really supported me uh
when I went to West Ham I had great men
who who helped me at that time as well I
think sometimes you need to be a bit
lucky on your journey that you know if
you turn up a club where an owner's
making the signings or you're not good
he's only going to give you half a dozen
games to to show what you can do you're
probably going to find it it's going to
be very difficult to succeed so
maybe a bit lucky at the start but I
worried much more when I was younger
than I would do now that success that
you want the time to achieve at West Ham
what what is that success what is the
goal for West Ham uh if we sat here in
you know let's say 10 years five years
time that's too long in football these
days five years time what's the what's
the goal
I think we've been successful yeah I
think West Ham have been successful in
the last two years
and what you know
really the one show the the great
winners in the serial winners are the
ones who wants to get a better success
all they want is more of it uh
I'd love to be sitting here where and
bringing my trophies in here in front
here and putting them up and saying here
look at these trophies I've not got that
what have I got I've got periods of
success and all my teams have done well
we've got to Europe you know got to a
cup final here and there we've got to
semi-finals
so not everybody in the industry can
have success you know not everybody can
know be what about with our medals and
at the moment have not but I still
believe there's still a big chance that
I can do that is that your kpi of
success is that what you
it's probably not now it's not now
because I actually think
staying in the job wouldn't be a bit
longevity is a really important thing in
anyone if you can stay in it and you can
it's no it's a big thing it's showing
that you've done a good enough job
but you know Avida I've been fortunate
enough with a few manager of the Year
Awards over over the years you know last
few years have been nominated for it but
I've said many times I'd swap it for one
of Jose mourinho's lemon Meadows if I
got the chance you know or one of these
trophies all day long so
that's still got to be what I'm driving
to do now well not gone forever because
I'm getting older and I don't want to be
as old as Sir Alex or Roy hodgin when
they finish those sort of people but but
I still get the energy I still get the
drive I feel as if I've got a good team
and I feel as if I'm still capable of of
keeping up with those younger ones quick
one we are lucky enough to have Intel
sponsoring this podcast and in previous
episodes I've introduced the Intel Evo
platform the badge of approval for
high-spec laptops that will enable you
to be more productive on the go all of
their designs are tested to make sure
they're extremely thin and making them
super portable and they also have a high
quality display and camera features for
example this Samsung device that I'm
using for those of you that are watching
on on YouTube or Spotify is super light
making it the perfect on-the-go device
whether I'm working in a plane or I'm in
the car or wherever I am on the go with
Intel Evo you don't need to sacrifice
you get the performance you need but in
a stylish and lightweight design so now
you know all you need to do is to look
for the Intel Evo badge to be assured of
performance and as always to find out
more head to intel.co.uk Evo quick one
from our longest standing sponsor hero I
I can't tell you over the last I'd say
over the last really it's been about two
and a half years it was really um post
pandemic how much my health has become
such a huge priority in my life and I
have this laser laser focused on what
I'm putting into my body it's funny
because as you get older you can start
to feel the things you're putting into
your body more and more and more
um and if I if I put something into my
body especially things like gluten if I
put those things in my body I feel them
tremendously the next day my energy
levels my sleep and everything in
between huel has been probably the most
important partner in my health Journey
because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it most of my
team that are in this room with me
consume it and get the benefits of it
too so if you haven't already tried your
do so
Alex sure Alex there's been a lot said
about Sir Alex I talk about him a lot
because I've interviewed so many of his
former players
um there was a lot of rumors that he
went to your house and asked you to
become the manager of Manchester United
no he took me to his house oh he took
you to his house yeah
and actually a
I'll tell you story Steve is I it wasn't
long after I turned 50 my wife had
bought me a watch and actually we had
gone through to Manchester too
to the Jaws I needed to get a link taken
out
and uh it was actually an altering on by
all places I was in altering them
and uh
the phone rang and it was a
it was Sir Alex and I saw the way I says
oh bloody hell it's Alex on the phone
and I thought oh he's gonna he's gonna
need one one of my players or he's going
to want me to take one of these players
which no he's he's coming on he says
something
and he and he said hey where are you
I I see something I'm in Manchester he
says uh well right come out to the house
when you're ready will you
said and that's a person Alex accent
probably so good
and uh
I see his sister wife
I can't do it I'm in my jeans I couldn't
go Easter Alex with a pair of jeans on
it's no way
so I'm saying oh what am I going to do
don't you Marks and Spencers and buy a
pair of trousers
you know so she said oh can we go just
go and get on me and do it so anyway
drop my wife off at the shopping center
and I drove out to Sir Alex's house
and and he went I went in
and he says then you come
and uh
very nice house and he's got a lovely
sort of room Sports room up the stairs
and he says what a cup of tea says I
took up a cup of tea
and he and he said
I'm retiring
and you're the next manager of
Manchester United
no interview
no no telling me not saying would you
like to be
no I'm retiring and I nearly slipped
down it was a it was a lesson I nearly
slipped down because obviously that was
nobody knew that sir Alex was retiring
nobody knew no nobody even suggested I
thought about it
and I nearly slipped down when I heard
them say that and then he says and
you're the next manager of Manchester
United
and I just sort of went yeah well no
okay I wasn't gonna I wasn't going to
turn around I didn't think I would ever
say nowhere I could I don't even know I
was in a position to say no and uh and
that was as simple as that we got
underway he said
and there was only maybe
and to be fair it was only four weeks to
go to the end of the season maybe five
weeks to go to the end of the season I
was coming out of contract to Everton
and I was really wanting to be
respectful to them and actually my next
game was against Liverpool
uh on this Sunday I think I met Sir Alex
in the midweek on the Wednesday or
something on the Sunday
and I knew that if we had got a draw
with Liverpool we would probably finish
above them in the league and it was at
anfield and we did we get a drop and we
we did finish up off them so it didn't
have any effect on on what I was doing
at Evan
but the big the big thing was to say and
then the next day said uh I want you to
come back to my house tomorrow uh
uh Edward was going to come and see he's
going to be the new chief executive who
he says David gills uh leaving as well
and that was it and I met Edward won the
next day and then the next day back to
his house again we met the glazers
and so it was three days three days
where I dropped back to his house the
the biggest problem I had was
he said
and you can't tell MD about me retiring
he says nobody knows that's no promises
tell your wife but nobody else I
couldn't tell my kids I couldn't tell my
dad
I couldn't tell my dad that I was going
to get the job but I was getting the job
so that that for me was how it happened
and when I wrote back now
to get that offer from probably arguably
uh the greatest the greatest manager
maybe there ever was was a great
compliment
uh
but maybe if I'd really looked in more
detail and more depths in in I was
desperate to be successful as a manager
and I had had 11 years at Everton where
we said weeds
would say we'd hit the glass ceiling but
we would find it really difficult to
break into the top four the competition
and the money was required
but my biggest regret was uh I was so
close to Bill Ken right the owner at
Everton
and I and I couldn't tell and it felt
and it was really bad that I couldn't
tell him because I was so close to Bill
but I couldn't break my word without Sir
Alex said he didn't want me to tell it
so I couldn't tell MD about my wife so
jump back in the car drove back to the
shop mall shopping center
got the wife put her in the car and I
said something new manager Man United
and she was like well you got piss off
your top rubbish you know so uh that was
it and that was how it went
you were coming to the end of your
contract with Everton at the time what
was your plan you hadn't signed a
contract so you must have been I hadn't
been I had I have to say as I had been
I think I would my plan was probably to
stay at Evan we just hadn't got it done
in for different reasons I was wanting
to see how it was going
but I have to say I'd I'd met a couple
other clubs I'd met a couple of really
big clubs who'd approached me and phoned
me and spoke to me you know what was I
doing would I be interested
the truth is I don't think I'd have I'd
have left for any of them
because everyone had been so good to me
but I was also wary about overstaying
your welcome at Evan you know sometimes
just in management supporters won't
change they want to want to try
something different and and I get it I'm
a huge football supporter you know if I
wasn't managing I'd be watching football
and I'd be you know probably talking
about it like everybody else does
but uh I
you know it came up I've got a chance to
manage probably the biggest cup in the
world I'm falling
a club who always give their managers
time they gave Sir Alex time and also
that their values were no they played
young players Man United
I always thought man united never went
out and tried to buy the best on the
market and they never went to the went
they never went to this sort of designer
shop to buy the best thing in the
designer shop they bought correctly they
bought young players they bought you
know you look at the Players they had
which they come through from Becks and
the Neville's and all the other ones who
came through
they always did something a bit a bit of
style about them they never went out to
get the best overseas manager in the
world they picked which fitted their
model
so I actually felt when Ceramics offered
me the job in Manchester United who had
given me the job I felt they thought I
must have been the best choice for the
job at that time and they saw that and
also maybe
not similar but similar in a way that
maybe there was a similar background a
similar upbringing a similar route maybe
to to get to the point so I trusted
Manchester United I really did adjusted
them because of what they stood for as a
football club
you know many times um when you're
successful as you were at Everton you're
given big opportunities it's the same in
business people come to me and give me
these huge opportunities and sometimes
like the bright bright lights of the
opportunity have often caused me to make
a wrong decision or not to take you know
take the right amount of due diligence
as you described they're like not really
looking into the details because it's
such a big thing that you almost can't
say no to it you said there that you
wish you'd looked a little bit closer
with the details what do you mean by
that
well I'll tell you who told me was uh
Howard Wilkinson said to me down the
line I wish you'd told me before he says
all the managers over the dynasty so
when you look at it uh I think it was
Brian cough was one of them I think the
other one was Sir Bobby Robson all the
managers who had the real uh
Dynasty and transdently United managers
as well uh don ravey maybe as well I
think it was
MD who followed them never worked
no I never even thought for a minute
because
I I thought to myself no I'll come in
and
and I actually was thinking I'm not
changing I'm going to try not to change
much of it so I said of course I have to
change it it's not Ceramics it's me and
I have to do it my way and I have to try
and do a little bit but ultimately uh I
was going to keep it going but then I'm
gonna when I look back at the things
what I heard I thought my goodness have
I looked a bit closer and maybe even now
I'm a bit older now than I was when I
get the job maybe maybe
even I needed even more experience and
maybe even I had it at that point maybe
we'd be more ready at this period in my
career than I was even saying no don't
know what it was eight or nine years ago
whenever it was
so if they called you now
well you know they've got a really good
manager I think and I think I think the
the thing about Manchester United
Manchester United have of chosen
incredibly good managers yeah rubber
with some of the best managers some of
the best managers you could ever imagine
I've been I've been at Manchester United
so you know sometimes you've got to say
you know if you're if you're quite
bright I'm sure you are with a business
you're working it's not always the
boss's fault it just doesn't this
doesn't go right so like I I took over
at a difficult time you know it was
quite a few senior players probably
coming to near the end of their time but
I also have to say I was really proud I
took over the Champions England when
when that was a time and that was I'm
saying what a chance I've got you know
maybe the opportunity to win trophies
the opportunity to be successful and it
was the thing I was probably missing
from a time at event that I wasn't quite
getting close enough to to winning
trophies would you would you Eric ten
hog aside I think he's great I think we
both agree there but would you ever be
open to coming back to Manchester United
in the future if they they'd asked uh
well I don't think it would ever be it
would ever been a role as a manager
that's for sure so that my time's gone
but
you know if ever I always love to be
involved in football and hopefully
somewhere along the line someone will
want to use my experience when my time's
up with we've been a football manager
but uh Manchester United is a great
experience and a and I found it
difficult to sort of have have something
which could sort out
I don't know how it would I would sort
of put over what it meant and the only
way I could put it out is I think when
you manage man united it's like living
in the penthouse and looking out
you know and until you've had the
penthouse and you're looking out and
you're above everybody and you're
looking over you see the view much
better and uh for me they were the
penthouse one of the big things that did
change at Manchester United and I only
know this because I had a season ticket
the ladies and the the men that serve
you the food in like the hospitality
suite or whatever they always have a
great relationship with them and they
would tell me things about how the club
was maybe before I could add enough
money to buy a season ticket one of the
things they always said was the role
that David Gill had on the club as well
yeah people don't think understand that
enough but David Gill was the CEO of the
club yeah and I mean I've seen in my own
businesses when the CEO me was removed
how much it was a completely different
place and people don't understand that
because as fans we look at the manager
and think ah but if the managers in my
business
are very very very important but the
person above them has the most power and
the most control in the most way is the
CEO now that changed and the the
wonderful people at Manchester United
would tell me that well when David Gill
was here he knew all of our names and
that really struck me that like he knew
all of our names he knew all of our
birthdays we used to see him now we
don't see yeah Ed Woodward anymore we
don't see the chief Executives anymore
they don't know our names that's a real
sign of a cultural change definitely
just think of the values with that is
yeah the values of the CEO sending your
Buster card or I don't know and I mean
like if we I would be incredibly
complimentary if it said Alex said Alex
would fall out managers who had lost a
job or managers who had been successful
he phoned me up when we were doing very
well at West Ham six months ago whenever
it was
it they were always correcting and when
you think of values of what it means to
be at the top and what the things small
things which matter those things really
matter but for me
I was taking over the club I'd lost
David Gill who I knew very well from
different things and working with them
at UEFA and different things as well and
he was a huge huge Miss but that wasn't
to say that the new CEO wasn't he was to
be giving every chance and I wanted to
help him and he wanted to help me
ultimately it didn't work that way you
said you trusted the club to give to
give you long enough do you feel like
that trust was let down yeah I do a bit
because I feel that you know
I think that
if you're putting in a new manager
you're hoping that you're going to give
them and look at least a very stable job
in a very good environment to come and
do it and obviously
no I think when you when we look back
you would say hey there was a huge
change going to have to take place at
Manchester United after Sir Alex and
maybe ideally I think it was we were
going to try and make it seamless where
there wasn't going to be too big a
change but there's a lot of players
changing uh you know getting to an age
where there were no having to move on
there was actually a big Squad of of
players who had been incredibly loyal to
Sir Alex and suddenly they've got new
managers coming in the door
maybe not playing them as much so they
don't have quite the same
sort of coarseness to to him and still
building up relationship so I think
there was I think there was a lot of
that and it made it difficult but you
know the the thing I I look back at
business in in you're a very successful
businessman
always think
you have to give bad news well
because you're the boss
and you run
a really big business like Manchester
United did and I think if you've got any
class or any style
it's good when you get off off the job
and then you give them when you give
them all they and you talk about also
but I think when you're having to get
bad news out I think even bad news has
to be done
in a good way as well and I felt the way
that the I was told at the same time at
Manchester United wasn't done as well as
it should have been done uh but the way
that you were told you weren't going to
be manager yes you know it was there was
there was ways it could have been done
better and it could be made a lot easier
than what it was no
I've heard this from former players I've
heard former players tell me that they
were really disappointed by how the club
um specifically Edward wood gave them
their send-off I think it was I think it
was Rio that said to me that like just
came into the dressing room tapped me on
the shoulder and told me that this was
my last game or that they were selling
me or something and that doesn't pay
respect no two no it doesn't and I
actually think that Looking Back Now hey
you think to yourself hey it's life got
on me you know that's the way it is when
you're you know you're in you're in an
industry or you're in you do that but I
still think that uh I think if you're
the biggest one of the biggest sport
businesses in the world if not the
biggest
you would hope that you would do things
correctly like David Gill would sound
speak and say hello to them or light
they would send a birthday card so the
same should happen if you were telling
somebody that you were you were stopped
number you're sacking them or you're
getting rid of them you would hope they
would do it the best way they could how
did how did you find out
uh media oh really media phone in me
yeah lost a couple I get it lost the
game at Everton actually in the media
was saying I know you're losing your job
and
you know I I try to make contacts and
and say like why don't we meet up you
think you're going a bit
it didn't certain before I knew they
called me and the day after and by this
time the whole world had known about it
before I'd sort of get you know got to
know so
sometimes I think people want to want to
get it done right and I just didn't feel
it was right but anyway from my point of
view
uh
I generally don't have any real I don't
know if I gripe about it because the
industry I'm in uh
means that this can happen quite often
and you don't get things done the way
you want it you have to live with it and
and that's the way it is in the wake of
that how does um what does it look like
at home this is probably one of the most
interesting things that I personally
pondered throughout that period as a
Manchester United fan which is when you
go from the penthouse and then the the
landlord evicts you from the penthouse
after I don't know 10 10 11 months at
the club
the what the weight of Manchester United
you know it's the most talked about Club
it's the club that sells the headlines
it gets all the clicks so every it must
feel like everything is about you in the
world of football and it's like a very
public apparent failure
at home you've got wonderful wife Pamela
you've got two kids what's it like at
home
I think I think personally you're a
little bit
shame because you've not done done well
you know you're not done well for your
family so
I think personally I felt I'd let them
all down because you know I I'd really
what like I said if nobody
probably the hours and the work I'd put
in as a young I didn't believe I was
ever going to be a coach never mind the
coach of Manchester United but the hours
of work had put in it got me to a level
where I'd worked and I'd done an awful
lot of hard work behind the scenes over
the years
on day than to lose it so quickly so you
get a job and I said at that time I had
two or three really really big co-ops
who were were talking about me speaking
to me but when Sir Alex came and made me
the offer it was very hard to say no
and then for that to go very quickly so
it was a bit like getting to top up
Everest and then actually starting to
decline very quickly so from my point of
view it was hardkin home you know it was
difficult
uh but I've got to say
it's a bit like
my mom used to just say hey whatever
happens you just have to get up and go
on with it you know you're on with it
you'd be taking the chin and you got
away and you know sort of sticks and
stones don't worry too much about it but
you're right when your manager of
Manchester United you talked about in
every continent every country you'll
either be in the front of the back page
it's one of the papers so
but that's also the privilege of being a
manager of Manchester United as well
what's the what's the toll of that if
you were to warn me about the time
I think the tool for someone who
cares deeply about their profession and
wants to be successful and wants to do
well the toll for me personally time
felt felt big it really did
and it's probably it probably took me a
wee bit to get back on the road a little
bit without saying about a watch really
after I lost the job I said well I'm
going to have to go and try and
reinvent find out more new things no
keep keep current where can I go to find
out what's going on you know and I
obviously couldn't go back to Old
Trafford to watch a game where I
couldn't really go back to to a
gooderson and watching him so it made it
quite difficult but I found myself doing
quite a bit of work for UEFA I'd done
all the Champions League games which was
really good day and and I spoke in all
the pro license courses for the coaches
which kept me current and having to keep
up to date with things so those those
type of things kept me kept my education
and kept my knowledge and kept me going
a bit better
I still think that when you when you
you've been at one of the big clubs it's
always a Miss because you realize the
the level they're at you said that the
toll is big in a very practical real
sense what does that mean
is it sleepless nights is anxiety is it
yeah yeah I'm someone who sleeps really
well to be honest
but I do think that
it's very difficult when you when you
lose your job in in our business you
know you've talked about a lot so you
have to accept it and I'm
a part of it you will be as well or if
things go wrong or any of your
businesses feel you'll be you'll be
current no people will have criticism
but I think if you're going to go into
football management then you have to
find a way of saying how they deal with
it how am I going with it what's my
mechanism uh
I remember thinking when things weren't
going so well at Manchester United you
know I'd be driving any training
so I couldn't put on Talk sport I
couldn't put on
Radio 2 I couldn't put the words on in
them but yeah so I thought I'll put on
uh whatever music it was
and they come on and he was never
talking about me on that news as well so
oh my goodness is this ever going to end
is it is there a channel it isn't
talking about Manchester United in some
way but that was because it was getting
closer to probably when I wasn't doing
so well and there's a lot of talk about
it but uh
I think you just have to find a way of
shutting yourself off from it the best
you can
but the world we're in now for young
coaches of social media if you if that's
what your your world is or or how you
present yourself
it's much different now and uh
in days gone by
in the early days at Preston I look at
the I look at the newspaper and there'd
be a letter page
and there'd be four or five supporters
saying
why is moy's not playing him you know
and what's he doing and that used to be
where the criticism was mainly coming
from as you well know now now there's a
world of it outside
I am I got to play a um the London
Stadium
I'll create it's not called London
Stadium isn't it yeah it's called the
Lindsay and awesome chat to Karen Brady
once a while I'm seeing her soon
um and uh I met someone while I was at
the soccer Aid experience who happens to
be a family member of a player a big
Premier League player who has taken more
abuse than any other player maybe over
the last year and I met a family member
and I got a chat to them and um they
told me about the toll it's taken on the
whole family and you never think about
that but that was actually one of the
most important things I think I
experienced was hearing from someone's
younger sister that watching that older
brother be abused how horrific is she
was almost in tears because you know if
you and my dad and I watched that happen
to you yeah well I have to say you know
and it's like I don't think of them I'd
only
a week half that I watched the man
united job my dad did a heart attack
yeah and it was but it was a triple
bypass so I'm not saying it was because
of when I left Manchester United but
that was that was the case and it hey
who knows who knows if it would then we
we don't really think that was the
reason behind it we think it was just
coming on but so there is tolls which
are taking in families of course there
is but thankfully my dad's doing well
and it's still going well just now
something we didn't think about you know
and people will say to to you and people
like you and players they'll say well
your payloads of money so behave
yourself yeah just deal with it yeah
yeah but that's but then the kids aren't
as there is part of it and actually I I
do think many many times I think myself
is you know do people understand it
we'll get a family you know uh I I made
this the other day is I was saying to a
friend of sinners as a manager I think
as you get older you no in business
you're you're older you you think you
get more experience than you're you know
doesn't make it any better when I was a
young manager if I lost the game
I would come home
go straight to my bed peel the curtains
and not wake up to Sunday morning no
trying and I might not sleep I just
didn't really want any I didn't have any
I didn't really talk with my wife too
much I didn't really talk to my kids I
wasn't I wasn't unpleasant I just wanted
to be on my own done that the opposite
then was if you won on a Saturday
I'd come home and say come on let's get
ready let's let's nip up to the
restaurant and we'll get a bit of dinner
and a couple glasses of wine
and I used to always call it the the
Saturday night feeling I'm desperate to
get that Saturday night feeling I'm
desperate to have that feeling when you
have one in a Saturday knowing that
Mainland is Sunday you're picking up the
newspapers and the newspapers are saying
you've won and you're you're going well
but
and I thought maybe by the time I get to
the Aging over a thousand games and I'll
be seeing myself this is going to be
much much feel much easier
not at all just as bad I'm not saying
I'm going home every every night I was
now and pulling the Cottons and going
straight to bed but it's to just sort of
tell you how how the game is the game is
actually nearly completely how important
they're winning and backed it I said
when the upbringing was where
find a way of winning win means that I
have more good Saturday night feelings
than I do
go home and put on the continents and
going straight to bed
yeah I don't think about that you know
you know when you you said something a
second ago which is
you know you'd you'd reached what I
consider to be the very top of the game
managing Everton because I think about
how many tens of thousands of managers
there are coaches out there that are you
know on the Sun the Sunday League
pitches and all around the country that
are aspiring to manage in the Premier
League it's insane it's an insane insane
achievement
um you manage to evidence you went to
Manchester United didn't go well in that
period after even though you're at the
very top of the game
did you doubt yourself
in a post Manchester United uh
by my pause might make you think yes but
I didn't doubt that I was actually I
felt that I could do do the job I could
be good at it I felt as if I could I
my work on the grass was was good enough
to
for where I had been I had success years
before so I was always trying to say it
didn't go quite well this 10 months why
did it not go well was it how romani's
was it how I coached was it maybe I
didn't have the right players I had to
try and look to see why there is
but the other part of the 10 or 11 years
I'd seen some great players that had
been in FA Cup finals I'd I'd got to
qualifying as a European competition
wherever and we'd we'd qualify for the
Champions League one year so I was
thinking as well was I going to make say
that was all no good then the years
would have done it so I think once I put
it in perspective then I says no I'm not
I'm not doubting it but what I do think
is
I think I think most days you have to
get up and be ready to sort of challenge
yourself every day I don't I don't think
you can go to bed every morning and
think hey this is fine you know I'm I'm
doing okay here I think every day you're
sort of get up and seeing as you know
how am I going to try and be better how
can I make people better what am I how
can I make a difference today with what
I've got paranoid almost yeah near
enough near enough to an extent what
you're saying there's no I can't no you
folks say do you bring your work home
I I really think if you're in
if you're in the boss if you're the boss
you're always bringing your work home
because it's not you're not just taking
putting your head off and saying I'm
leaving that in the office and I'll pick
it up in the morning I think very really
you're doing that I think that's just
life of your if you're a CEO or a boss
I very much agree I very much agree with
that idea of taking the working and also
when things don't go wrong in hindsight
everybody's quick to diagnose why I
didn't go wrong
um has the subsequent 10 years where
everyone is failed at Manchester United
felt good
because everyone has failed Jose's
failed van Hal went there you went there
um I'm missing someone I think I'm
missing someone I mean Ollie was in it
Ollie was in he failed as well so that's
you know five or six great great
managers who
you couldn't make it work at Manchester
United for whatever reason so I think
time has almost been
good to you in terms of your yeah the
story of the time like I'm I I I get
huge respect for uh Josie Mourinho
huge result for Louis van Gaal you know
all he was new and is one of one of
Manchester United's own so was always
going to be given every opportunity to
try and make it work as well so I think
that I think there's been some great
managers coming into Manchester United
I think the biggest problem for
Manchester United is Manchester City
how do we I'm a Manchester United fan
season ticket holder how from your
experience do we get things back to how
they were
I think you'll need to
probably get rid of Pep somehow I think
that's my that's what we uh I think I
think papers I think there is some
managers I think but you must have an
unbelievable perspective better than me
at like what because you knew Fergie you
knew the club everything you've been
inside it what what do we need to do to
get back to
I think Manchester United different
principles and than most of the other
clubs
looked at their use a lot uh didn't
always sign maybe the as I said before
maybe the the top yeah Diamond always
sort of picked and picked out good
players who improve and now and again
went and bought a Canton over so often
or uh by nistel Roy or Van Percy at
different times you know uh so at
different times they they bought really
good players at Good Times this is
actually a really good point because
we've also bought some world-class
places and they've all failed yeah so
there is it there is something about
Manchester United had their own way but
because of the competition which came in
from Manchester City
uh Chelsea probably more in the in the
earlier years I think those two clubs I
think I think Liverpool have have an
incredible pier and get a really good
manager as well and top players
I think over the year Man United and
Liverpool have always had a level of
competition against each other people
say we've not spent money in terms of
players we've spent shitloads of money
we spent almost a billion huge whatever
huge and all these players I remember
the foul cows the demerick because I get
excited every time and I celebrate and I
start you know blowing up my friends
WhatsApp chats and saying you're screwed
we're going to win the league yeah and
then every year the player fails and
then the managers sacked yeah so it
feels like a bit of a it's the
expectation of the excitement on the new
players coming in I get this all the
time and I say this quite a lot too
people are here in media you know it's
on a bit oh you need to buy new players
no we buy new players
and I said
I I would really like football to be
where money was not always going to be
the key to you know we think the more
players you see the more money you spend
uh means that you win the league or
you're successful and look I think it
probably will prove that it is
but I'd rather see that you know
sometimes that it's not that way
and I just do think that
quite often you know not buying all the
top players it doesn't mean that you
have to buy the top but I think it's
buying good players and people who get
good characters and people who are going
to gonna work hard for the team and then
they come into that culture which makes
one makes yeah which makes the
difference
of that year yeah less than the year
they had was was probably what we're all
hoping for whether it be us and
now you've seen other clubs I mean
actually Newcastle United for example
Newcastle United bought a couple of uh
with respect to three or four English
players last January British players uh
probably not necessarily on the radar of
the biggest clubs in the country
and it and and they've turned around and
they've had a great they've had an
incredible momentum from probably
January last year and maybe just before
January and are keeping that momentum
going and now they're bringing in the
Reddit in the odd bigger star or the
bigger players as they go along but I
thought the business at the start was
very good if I'm one of your players in
your dressing room
to be a David Moyes player at West Ham
and what would from a character and a
personality standpoint your expectation
be of me
so that I fit into the culture and I'm
successful
I'd want you to be
I'd like you to be hard working I want
you to be honest in your endeavor
I I know I'd want you to do your jobs
whatever you want I want you to be a
team player
the individuals are really important and
no more hugely important we've just seen
in the World Cup individuals but but I I
do think that I I think
to have a consistency about your teamers
you need to have a team
I think if you've got individuals you
might get inconsistency but you may get
some really good days and where you get
Club so you can afford to carry one or
two individual players who go along but
I think well you're trying to build
build I think you have to start with a
really solid base good foundation and
then from that point you try and grow
Pamela you met her at a disco yeah
she was lucky
yeah so I keep telling them it's uh most
people disagree
she's been through it all with you you
know the everything she's followed you
around for decades and supported you in
many many ways and um I've heard about
the sort of dynamic in your relationship
where she's been really really
supporting you kind of do a lot of it
together you're there for each other
tell me in your own words what like uh
what she means to you I guess
well it's the sort of thing you ask that
question you'd probably get emotional if
you start saying that so I'm going to
say that before I start
uh look my wife has been unbelievable
towards me because I remember when we
were young at about what we said is we
didn't earn great money I wasn't I
wasn't a hugely
wealthy footballer when I was getting
paid but I wanted to play football and
would have taken away so
Pamela worked as well
and we had to opt to pay the mortgage
when we were together we were there so
we're it was very much that a together
at the start how we could sort of have a
family how we could we could work
together
and I remember saying to her I said no I
I might need to be a football coach and
I remember when we were courting I said
look
I'll need to go to coaching course and I
might not be here and I need to I want
to try and go and see her it doesn't
remember saying no problem you're going
to do what you have to do and if I
wasn't given that
freedom in nearly years to say good
coaching courses I mean
I went out to see enchilada ACI Moana
I went to the World Cup uh
and I have to say you know I remember I
went to the World Cup and I and because
I didn't have like somebody at the time
and and we weren't skinned but we didn't
have loads of in the PFE helped fund me
so I think at the time the PFA helped
fund me get to the World Cup to go and
watch I remember writing to
I wrote to about five or six countries
and said you know could I come and watch
your training
and none of them replied the only
country I replied was Scotland and Craig
Brown was a manager now I was a Scottish
coach and worked in and not and I was
still young at the time and they invited
me to come and watch training school and
none of the other teams did but my wife
let me get away and get on with it and
try and seek and find out what I needed
to do probably in the hope that
somewhere after my football career was
finished that I might have been able to
do something else but she was she still
has a great inspiration to me uh
and show my kids my kids are good kids
and you know good family and it's really
important to me what role has she played
Pamela in the in the harder times in
your career
you know I think I think
when you're when you're a football
manager you're going to have hard times
so undoubtedly
it's a hard time's been a football
manager hey hard times sometimes mean
you get sacked and you get you get some
money for leaving the job you can look
at that and say hey he's okay with that
but it's not you've got Pride you know
as I said yeah I was probably losing a
job I was more an embarrassment I felt
embarrassed
from from a family really that you know
they were getting talked about they were
getting looked at no
people were shouting now your dad's lost
his job or whatever it may be at that
time so
my wife's just always stood by me and
really supported me whenever it comes to
the games
uh probably knows when she should speak
when she shouldn't speak when it's going
well when it's going badly and even
that's a skill in itself because you
know
when you're in a when you're the boss
that's quite often would respect your
partner quite often could say the wrong
thing at any minute and you and you go
no you might be saying why are you not
thinking about no you're in the wrong
case so I think it's really important
that your partner understands exactly
how you feel well where do you think
you'd be professionally without her uh I
couldn't imagine in it I couldn't
imagine my my life really without my
wife and and you know sometimes I'm not
59 at the moment so I thought we'd get a
good bit to go we've got a good bit to
go
and I want you to look forward to the to
the years where latter years together
where we can have more time together
because
being a football manager means that
you know we're just about every weekend
so yeah either way staying in a hotel
preparing for a game or you're you know
you're
with a team and actually the way
football's gone you're in every Sunday
now you could be in all the time there's
very little family time and it and
actually it's one of the things I think
what people don't understand hey by the
way it's a great job really well paid
game everybody wants to be involved
energy but it's incredibly time
consuming you know and it takes up so
much of your time interview if you have
a family
probably they're the ones who suffer
most because they don't see you as much
as well probably other families may do
if you work uh Monday sort of nine till
five you go home at the weekends at
least uh being a football manager the
weekends uh you're doing it and actually
I'm trying to get a membership with a
golf club at the moment back in my home
I can't get in because in the sea well
no you've got to play away you've got to
play with members and you've got to play
with friends to get an absent I've got
no friends in the business we're in it's
really hard to have lots of friends
outside of our industry the reason why
is because a social time when focusing
here we're going out Friday night we're
going out Saturday night you're coming
with us no I'm in the hotel we've got a
game tomorrow we can't do that or we go
out Saturday night yeah but I lose
obviously I'm not gonna lose Saturday
night so lots of reasons why uh
even a football manager does a great job
but it's also got lots of anti-social
Behavior things because of how the job
Works Alia you said that you you haven't
been historically so good especially
when you're a younger at
um giving praise I can relate one of the
things that men are particularly bad at
is um letting and I'm speaking about
myself here is letting their significant
other know how much they appreciate them
I think women are usually better at kind
of that that affection and saying the
kind words and stuff and as men I know
this for myself I don't think my partner
actually has a clue how much she means
to me and how much she's been there for
me in the hottest times and just her
presence sometimes when she says nothing
in the hard moments how that changes my
state
um if Pamela is watching this
what are the words you wish you could
tell her that maybe you haven't told her
uh she would probably know that a lover
of course she would I would hope she
would but more importantly that I miss
her because I'm in London a lot of the
time she's she's up north she's caring
for her mom a lot at the moment
I just really over the time she's been
she's been great we've we've had great
times together and but always want to
say I think my best times in in football
Hope was still to come but hopefully her
best time is a couple are still to come
as well
David thank you thank you for lots of
inspiration over the many many many
years and lots of good memories in
football
um you've been an incredible manager all
the clubs you've been at in my view and
I do wish that Manchester United had
given you more of a chance because I
just generally believe everything you
say about the importance of when when
you come into a new system or
organization needing that time to
understand and make it your own so even
as a Manchester United fan I was always
I'm always really annoyed at how quickly
we've
um moved on with our managers before
giving them a chance because they're all
objectively great managers and you
certainly are as well
um and it's just an honor to meet you
because you know I've watched you on the
screens for for decades so thank you we
have a closing tradition on this podcast
where the last guest asks a question for
the next guest
um
and the question left for you is
what is the biggest public misconception
about something that has happened in
your life
uh
after thinking about it I think that
there was a
I felt it was a few untruths at the end
when I lost my job at Manchester United
actually
and I found it very difficult to correct
I felt that you know they had been
written so it was very difficult to
correct them uh you know which they
weren't right and uh from that point of
view I couldn't turn about it and I
found that actually
probably one of the biggest difficulties
because you try you want to say well
here I'll explain why I made this
decision I'll explain why I chose to do
that uh but really once the headline's
there that's the only thing that matters
you've got to give me one yeah which I
think I won that's what I think uh
I've got I've got this one but I don't
know if I don't want to give the
player's name
so uh I mean it was actually uh so
somewhere like they said that Manchester
United had banned chips on a Friday Rio
had said in his book that had banned
chips I read that yeah I did and uh it
was actually
something which
probably most sports profession you
wouldn't really have chips but then in
part of it but understood Manchester
United Sir Alex done a lot a lot of
things maybe slightly different in I
totally respected that and what happened
is I remember it was one of my first
first games were staying in the hotel
and there was one player who was
overweight which I won't name
and I remember walking in and I was
walking into the dining room and he had
his dinner and next to me they had a
side plate of chips
and that was my reason for after that
scene that one player without the side
portionship that was my reason for
saying there should be no chips on a
Friday night and it was sort of written
about that that was one of the the
reason but my reason was actually
because one of the players who was
actually at the time a bit overweight a
song with a with a side player chips and
that's when I used our band them if you
want to say that interesting thank you
so much David for your time thank you so
much thank you
[Music]
quick one from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better as some of you may know
by now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio I actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]